with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
Google's vision for a safer web then
stay tuned because here's the rewind
over the past year we've seen amazing
growth from large and small companies
who are embracing the web for
productivity
this means coworkers are relying on the
web more and more for things like
collaboration remote working and the
cloud-based services that help them
accomplish their goals each day sadly
attackers are following this trend as
well and getting more creative we've
seen more attacks each year and more
variety in the kinds of attacks
completely new attacks are appearing as
well
most of these attempt to gain control of
high-value accounts so the attacker can
use the credentials for their own
purposes which means that the defense
that's probably you he needs new
strategies to and Google is here to help
we've been rolling out more tools and
features to Chrome to help secure your
company's resources and keep your
employees safe at Google were very
familiar with these kinds of attacks we
see over 6,000 instances of unwanted
software attacks each minute targeting
over 3 billion devices around the world
and thanks to our Safe Browsing tools we
can learn from these attacks and
recognize new vulnerabilities
automatically and here's the best part
your IT administrator can get access to
the same tools and capabilities through
Chrome policies letting them see what
warnings were circumvented and what
common sites are attack vectors on your
domain to keep your password safe you
can use password alert which can notify
admins when an internal password has
accidentally been used for an external
site this helps fight phishing and
password sharing vulnerabilities but
security isn't just a one-way street
starting with chrome 68 non-http
websites will be identified as not
secure helping us create a web that's
safer from eavesdropping even with
strong web encryption new vectors keep
emerging with specter and meltdown
we saw machines around the world
suddenly at risk we reduced the ability
for malicious code to spread with
sandboxing originally we built chrome
with tab sandboxing which prevents tabs
from interfering with each other now
with site isolation different sites in
one tab cannot affect each other or
leaked
thanks for watching you can see a link
to the full talk in the description
below subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more next rewind videos
[Music]
you